[Music]
another tech talk video
yes i was hoping he would make another
tick tock video
i know you are welcome this is why i'm
losing against t-series listen up kid
tick-tock is spending ads
on television okay i'm getting that
braid papa needs that brain
don't discriminate watch the video
let's just jump and i get something what
are you holding
up oh it's a microphone
you know when is this meme going to die
never this girl will just be bullied
into infinity
[Music]
you gotta appreciate it it's like
everyone wanted vine to come back
here it is this is it i'm starting to
you know
i'm okay with it you know what i'm okay
with it you know what
i like tic toc screw you haters
why do i have the green screen if i
can't even key out my sweater
this is how real gamers play just
massage your friend's scalp
that's how you unlock a text
[Music]
oh damn
how did he do that can we get a replay
on that one brad
he's the chosen one i love the dead face
as well
you know something is wrong when people
stacking cups
are bullying you welcome to 2018
where the bullied bullies you i love it
it's fantastic
no not november no not
life
[Music]
think about that for all of you that
failed no not november
think about the people with no arms how
do you think they feel
okay bullseye right here watch this
god damn it it's none of your life you
lose look i'm still in the game
they're so dumb i kind of like it though
you know because youtube has always been
overflown with these stupid uh vines
that make me want to die
or weinstein makes me want to go to the
dentist or
vines that makes me want to finger my
just to see if it smells bad down there
but now we finally just have tick-tock
videos again and all you have to do is
replace the music
and you got yourself a cpm like the ad
pocalypse never happened baby
because i guess i don't care take two
steps forward
if you've ever gotten a victory royale
take two steps forward if your dad loves
you
take two steps forward if your minecraft
girlfriend broke up with you
i don't know why minecraft girlfriends
out of all breeds
have to be the thoughtions of them all
you think you meet someone that truly
matters you think
you think you meet someone that you can
finally settle down with never fall for
a minecraft girlfriend
they'll break your goddamn heart after
they break your house like a creeper
in the dark
all right i i take back pretty much
everything positive i've said
about tick-tock jesus christ this is
what kids are doing these days
you know what i i got an idea and i
stick a phone in my
mouth print a dozen papers of hand
emojis
and that will get me the clout on the
internet that i deserve
[Music]
i don't know i don't know what i was
expecting
this is uh that's the footage of me
uploading a video to youtube
let's get this bread i don't know why i
have the green screen i ca
like what is this why is it reflecting
on me what is happening
i'm disappearing guys oh wait no
you know what brad is just gonna
complain so it's too late i might as
well commit
oh my god they're so dumb that it's just
the perfect humor it's just
it's the perfect humor for you for you
for you dumb boss
okay i only laugh at smart stuff
what is this oh my god
i wish i wish that was my dad
[Music]
oh my god
okay that was good well play
i almost got angry there for a second
how could i be so
easily swayed grand theft auto
roblox is one of my favorite games if
the furries ever have you down
just remember good girls want to be
tracer
boys go to college to hit the dab like
with khalifa
and weebs go to pluto to get killed by
naruto
jesus christ weeps go to pluto
to get killed by naruto that
is deep like this video this left a
profound impact on your life
oh my god
[Music]
i'm actually terrified what in the world
oh my god jesus
i want to know where that is is that
real we stand as family when you don't
get that bread we give you the bread
everybody take a slice pass it down this
is what i'm talking about don't get that
bread
tick tock bread when you don't get that
everyone gives you the bread let's go
pass it down come on all right it's not
that great
but it's a kind of laugh worthy at least
it's chuckle worthy at least
it's kind of like my videos you know
there's no redeeming quality
they're really not that funny but uh
people seem to watch it anyway
that's it we found it it's a perfect
match
outdated memes um
i say more i don't think
why am i laughing at this come on it
can't i don't know why i have to keep
making a case for every single one of
them
like okay yeah that was maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
it's officially gone too far it's
official
you know what i keep saying i say that
every episode and then it goes further
jesus christ
oh my god
uh i'm scared
i'm beginning to get scared this is only
the beginning of tick tock it's only
been relevant for like what
a month i don't want to know how this
looks like the next year
okay supposedly if you can hear this
you have a higher iq okay now i'm going
to play a sound and you think of the
word brainstorm
help me now i'm gonna play the same
sound and you think of the words green
needle
please call the police i've been held
captive for over
peyton says recently i was looking
through my daughter's phone and i found
many pictures of a cartoon skeleton with
one glowing blue eye
and wearing a hoodie when i asked my
daughter why she had such demonic images
on her phone she told me there was
nothing wrong with it because it was
from a video game
it's sans it's freaking sans okay
i get it one tick tock too many
i definitely won't make any more you
have my full honest
word on that one you can trust you can
rely on me no more tick tock videos i
swear
thank you so much for watching this
video if you enjoyed smash like
subscribe
i don't see why you wouldn't honestly
has t-series beat me yet
i don't see how that's possible i
uploaded a tick tock video that's
okay bye